[Music]
demi lovato the sorry not sorry singer
clearly making no apologies for who she
is or who she loves what is it like for
you to sort of open up your world scary
it's scary for sure you know I talk
about a lot of things that I haven't
talked about in interviews tweeting
quote if you're that curious about my
sexuality watch my documentary her
YouTube special simply complicated for
premiere in October the topic of her
sexual orientation became a source of
speculation last week when she was
photographed holding hands with DJ
Lauren Abedini at Disneyland and most
the single 25 year old woman living on
her own and really feel like an adult I
feel like I've done a lot of growing and
my album is a result of that making no
apologies for what it took to get to
this healthy place of strength and
gratitude I was exclusively behind the
scenes of Demi's vivo live performance
it premieres September 29th the same day
her new album tell me you love me drops
there's some interesting song titles and
of course he released the track listing
on Instagram
[Music]
so you don't do it for me anymore is the
song for me as a double meaning breaking
up with my old self and my addiction and
my alcoholism not going back to those
old ways that I always resorted to
because it doesn't do it for me anymore
they used to feel sorry for myself now I
have a different perspective on life
where I'm feeling grateful and and happy
and I'm just in a totally different
place
[Music]
you